well there is a concern tonight with
those cases more children are testing
positive
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to a mother who says
she along with her three children all
have the virus
sally denise kayla stringer is a single
mother of three she along with her
children are trying to recover from coed
she's hoping that by her sharing her
story tonight everyone takes the most
recent restrictions
very seriously i can't quarantine and
get better
because i have three other kids who are
sick the sweats have not gone away for
the last two weeks i have those
headaches have not gone away my sense
and smell comes and goes
kayla stringer tested positive for covet
last week
she took her three kids ages 10 9 and 4
to get tested too
i got the results from my for one of my
kids on friday afternoon
that was positive then i got a call
yesterday morning which is monday
that my youngest and my oldest also are
positive with cover 19.
i was shocked i kind of had a panic
attack stringer says she is monitoring
their breathing and temperatures and
making sure they drink plenty of fluids
evelyn stanton with the unlv school of
medicine says covet cases
among children is not uncommon as a
matter of fact
since the pandemic we've had like a
1.2 million children with cobra 11
percent of our children
nationwide that has been exposed to
covet
and just this week alone we've had like
144
000 uh children uh with confirmed cases
from newborns to up to age
19 parents also need to monitor their
children
and i think the hardest part with these
children
is that some may be asymptomatic and
still
be carrying the virus or have very mild
symptoms
and that's an issue some of the symptoms
may include
low fever sore throat and muscle aches
if he
can wear his mask outside the house with
no problem
these adults should be having a problem
although kids covet cases are on the
rise recent data
show symptoms to be mild and the
majority of the kids fully recover but
just
like you and i children need to take
precautions too
make sure they wear their masks and wash
their hands reporting live near the
strip
sally jaramillo 8 news now